what's the deal with you because
everybody says you're like paid by the
DNC everybody says your shells right or
a lot of people not everybody but
there's a a group of people on the
internet saying it because you guys
scream at your phone you're very
passionate videos about that you love
Biden who's a man of what 70 years your
senior how old is he
he's 80 now I think he's 80. can you
move the mics closer if you're gonna be
that quiet I mean you've never been that
quiet in your life oh sorry okay loud
now all you do is yeah now you're not
like soft-spoken and quiet and
considered or you're literally all
you've done is free and now this is the
first time
oh
[Music]